des rafales à 170 kilomètres heure qui
déracine les arbres arrache les toitures
et ne faiblissent pas en entrant dans
les terres la tempête de 1999 est
surnommé tempête du siècle
cette tempête elle a donc balayé toute
la moitié nord de la france dont elle a
touché en plus un territoire très
important donc la conjugaison de
l'intensité du phénomène et de la
superficie touchée rend le phénomène
d'autant plus exceptionnel à orléans un
couple péri au dernier étage d'un
immeuble dans l'effondrement de la
cheminée deux morts dans la région et
des sinistrés par centaines de milliers
c'était l'apocalypse
on avait vraiment peur que les âmes tous
les arbres tombés de tous les côtés ça
tombait partout katia mercier à 7 ans 99
à villiers au besoin dans l'ouest de
l'indre-et-loire la ferme familiale est
parmi les premières habitations touchées
dans la région réveillé dans la nuit son
père sera inspecté le disjoncteur
et là on a vu la toiture la toiture
était complètement l'air est tombé juste
derrière mon père ouais c'est une image
qui m'a perturbé puisque c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu mon père
d'avoir peur de venir tout blanc nous
dire voilà c'est peut-être les derniers
moments qu'on va passer ensemble parce
qu'il me dit moi j'ai peur de cet
événement katia garde panique et
angoisse lors de chaque tempête dans
l'eure-et-loir daniel était sapeur
pompier il est bipé au petit matin le 26
décembre et prendre des photos des
dégâts
certaines j'ai senti que c'était
important mais je pense qu'on mesure pas
tout de suite
l'ampleur de la chose quoi c'est après
où furent mesure prenait déjà quand on
est arrivé à l'accasion que c'était le
branle bas de combat parce que il ya les
des appels de partout les gens sont
paniqués forcément tout le monde veut
les secours tout de suite près de trois
cent mille foyers privés d'électricité
des gars inondations jamais les sapeurs
pompiers n'auront été submergés d'appels
comme en décembre 1999